y
continúa el asedio ruso sobre la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol la planta de azov
tal sigue siendo el último bastión de
las fuerzas ucranianas donde las
autoridades aseguran que también hay
muchos civiles desde eeuu aseguran que
los socios de ucrania han proporcionado
más equipamiento militar
la agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados anunció que el número de
ucranianos que han huido al extranjero
desde el inicio de la guerra ha superado
ya los 5 millones y 71 millones de
personas se desplazaron dentro del país
en total más de 12 millones abandonaron
sus hogares
enmanuel macrón y marine lepén se
enfrentan este miércoles en el esperado
debate presidencial de cara a las
elecciones del próximo domingo en esta
emisión echaremos un vistazo al detrás
de la escena del encuentro y conoceremos
cómo fue preparado
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 o 6 rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos este
informativo en ucrania y nos enfocamos
en la ciudad de mariupol que sigue
asediada por las tropas rusas en el día
56 de la invasión la inmensa planta
siderúrgica de asostel sigue siendo el
último bastión de las fuerzas ucranianas
donde también se refugian civiles rusia
dio un nuevo ultimátum a las tropas de
ucrania que siguen sin rendirse y se
anunció un acuerdo preliminar para la
apertura de corredores que faciliten la
evacuación de unos 6000 civiles el
asesor de la presidencia ucraniana instó
a todos los ciudadanos a que utilicen
esos corredores al máximo entretanto la
ofensiva se intensifica en el este del
país en donde los bombardeos han
impactado varias zonas residenciales y
el ejército ucraniano pide cada vez más
asistencia militar para resistir los
ataques veamos el informe
la planta de acero a soft al en la
ciudad portuaria de mariupol bajo el
constante asalto de las fuerzas rusas es
el ultimo bolsón de resistencia
ucraniana en la ciudad desde hace días
los combates ucranianos se han
atrincherado allí
y según las autoridades también miles de
civiles refugiados bajo la fábrica los
soldados asediados escasos de alimentos
lanzaron un llamado desesperado en las
redes sociales para pedir ayuda
nos enfrentamos quizás a nuestros
últimos días sino horas el enemigo nos
superan en número 10 a 1 muy alta vamos
apelamos y suplicamos a todos los
líderes mundiales que nos ayuden les
pedimos que utilicen el procedimiento de
extracción y nos lleven a territorio de
un tercer estado un proyecto de traders
aragón el presidente ucraniano dice que
su petición a rusia de una evacuación no
ha sido atendida lamentablemente no
hemos tenido ninguna respuesta de rusia
a la oferta de intercambio que podría
salvar a los civiles y defensores de
mariupol y este silencio debe ser notado
por todos los que han estado pueden
estar asociados con rusia rusia ha
intensificado sus ataques en todo el
frente del este en su punto de mira
ciudades como es lo bians trama torch
con esta ofensiva rusia afirma haber
entrado en una nueva fase de guerra
el ejército ruso está llevando a cabo
las tareas establecidas por el jefe del
ejército para la operación militar
especial se están aplicando el plan de
liberación de las repúblicas populares
de donges y lugansk así como las medidas
para restablecer la paz
- rusia sigue lanzando asaltos contra
las demás ciudades asediadas en jarquín
al menos cuatro personas murieron el
martes en bombardeos contra zonas
residenciales
como veníamos avanzando rusia prosigue
su avance sobre el este de ucrania el
asesor de la presidencia ucraniana
confirmó que las tropas rusas concentran
sus esfuerzos en la ciudad de siún en el
noreste en dirección a la cercana slob
ians según el funcionario rusia habría
iniciado también el asalto sobre rue
business y popas ni en la región de
lugansk por el momento afirman desde
ucrania han conseguido frenar los
ataques de moscú que hasta ahora no han
difundido reportes de la situación
y el presidente del consejo europeo
charles michel viajó este miércoles aquí
para reunirse con volodymyr selenski y
mostrar su solidaridad con ucrania
michelle aseguró que hasta el momento
bruselas ha proporcionado 1.500 millones
de euros en ayuda a ucrania el
funcionario europeo confirmó que había
despachado también conceden skip sobre
el cuestionario que font der leyen le
había entregado anteriormente de cara a
la adhesión de ucrania a la unión
europea
propuestos
en cuanto a nuestra futura adhesión a la
unión europea es una prioridad para
nuestro estado para la fuerza de nuestro
pueblo que está dispuesto a defender
nuestra tierra contra los invasores
rusos incluso sin armas
y ya son más de 5 millones los
refugiados que han cruzado la frontera
de ucrania huyendo de la guerra así lo
anunció este miércoles la agencia de la
onu para los refugiados acnur señalando
que otros 7 como millones de personas se
han desplazado a otras regiones dentro
del territorio ucraniano debido a los
brutales enfrentamientos que se viven
sobre en el este del país
marina sardiña tiene los detalles
a medida que aumenta la ofensiva rusa en
el este de ucrania se incrementa también
el número de desplazados y refugiados
que huyen de sus hogares en un intento
por salvar sus vidas más de 5 millones
de ucranianos han abandonado el país
según la agencia de la onu para los
refugiados y el número de refugiados que
huyen a través de las fronteras siguen
aumentando a diario así que en menos de
dos meses unas ocho semanas hemos visto
una cuarta parte de la población de
ucrania más de 12 millones de personas
en total incluidos 5 millones de
refugiados pero también unos 75 millones
de personas dentro del país que se han
visto obligadas a huir de sus hogares
polonia ha recibido a más de la mitad de
ese éxodo casi tres millones la mayoría
mujeres niños y ancianos
víctor y ya es una de las refugiadas en
la capital polaca salió con sus dos
hijas de mariupol la sitiada ciudad
portuaria donde se han vivido
enfrentamientos brutales que han dejado
una urbe en ruinas
queríamos irnos inmediatamente porque
todas las casas de alrededor estaban
destruidas nos sentamos en los sótanos
con miedo a salir todo fue saqueado la
gente quería comer tampoco teníamos agua
muestra su gentil dije que como esto se
llama build restricción lloramos todos
tenemos la sensación de que no hay hogar
no se sabe dónde ir qué hacer a dónde
huir eso da mucho miedo
badín y muchos esperan poder regresar a
sus hogares desde el inicio de la
invasión del kremlin más de un millón de
exiliados ucranianos han retornado a
ucrania a las zonas todavía controladas
por las fuerzas ucranianas
constatamos que en ese periodo de tiempo
uno como millones de nuestros ciudadanos
entraron en ucrania
se trata de la crisis de refugiados con
mayor crecimiento en europa desde el
final de la segunda guerra mundial unas
cifras que rozan las de otros sexos
actuales como el sirio con casi 7
millones de refugiados después de más de
10 años de guerra
rusia aseguró haber probado su misil
balístico intercontinental
sharman un arma que según el presidente
ruso vladimir putin hará pensar dos
veces a quienes intentan amenazar a
rusia el misil fue lanzado desde play
sets en el noreste del país y alcanzó
objetivos de la península de kamtchatka
en el extremo oriental de rusia según
putin es capaz de burlar todos los
sistemas antimisiles actuales
esta arma verdaderamente única
fortalecer al potencial de combate de
nuestras fuerzas armadas asegurará
confiablemente la seguridad de rusia de
las amenazas externas y hará que
aquellos que el calor de la retórica
agresiva traten de amenazar a nuestro
país y lo piensen dos veces puede que no
sea extraño nos vamos ahora hasta españa
porque allí se vive este miércoles el
primer día tras el decreto del fin del
uso obligatorio del tapabocas en
interiores salvo en algunos casos
específicos como los hospitales o el
transporte público nuestra corresponsal
en madrid marina colorado nos cuenta más
desde la principal estación de trenes de
la capital española
setecientos días después de su
imposición el uso de las mascarillas en
interiores en españa' ya no es
obligatorio la medida tiene excepciones
como por ejemplo dentro de centros y
servicios sanitarios y también dentro
del transporte público no así en las
estaciones como por ejemplo en esta de
atocha en el centro de la capital
española eso sí la mayoría de las
personas continúan llevando la la
noticia no ha sido recibida de la misma
manera por la ciudadanía sobre todo con
una diferencia de respuesta según las
edades pues yo lo veo bien la verdad
creo que ahora la pandemia ya está más
controlada y la verdad que creo que es
una medida que es positiva se supone que
se hace lo de acabar con las mascarillas
porque la situación epidemiológica ha
mejorado pero también es verdad que hay
gente que es más vulnerable o que tiene
inmunodeficiencia o que tiene algún
problema alguna patología y por lo tanto
pues entiendo que esa gente se proteja
con la mascarilla que es hasta ahora la
medida que tiene a mano en los comercios
o en los lugares de trabajo dependerá de
cada empresa a decidir si es obligatorio
o no y lo tendrán que decidir después de
hacer una evaluación el riesgo laboral
que suponga el no llevar la mascarilla
para los empleados hemos preguntado a
varios de ellos y la mayoría dice que
seguirá llevando la mascarilla aunque
muchos de ellos decían que su empresa no
les ha dicho si todavía sigue siendo
obligatoria algunos de ellos o la
mayoría lo hacen por seguridad personal
en la empresa es opcional nos han dado a
elegir si preferimos llevarla o no
más que nada por precaución si una
persona con problemas respiratorios y de
momento
el fin de las mascarillas en interiores
es un paso más en la estrategia del
gobierno español frente a la convivencia
con el kobe 19 un paso que dependerá en
gran medida de decisiones personales y
de cambios de costumbres tras 2 años
incorporando el tapabocas como elemento
esencial de nuestra rutina y hoy es el
día en el que se enfrentan en manuel
macro ni marie le pen en el tan esperado
debate previo a la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales del domingo en
francia los últimos sondeos muestran que
el presidente francés y aspirante a la
reelección aventaja a la candidata de
extrema derecha sin embargo el índice de
votantes indecisos se mantiene alto
este es el plato donde se celebrará el
debate presidencial francés para este
crucial cara a cara todo ha sido
acordado de antemano por las dos
campañas atrás queda la gran mesa que
compartieron emanuel mcqueen marine
lepén durante el debate de 2017 en su
lugar dos mesas más pequeñas una para
cada candidato separadas por dos metros
y medio los dos periodistas que moderan
estarán sentados juntos a cuatro metros
de distancia siete segundos internos es
muy diferente una entrevista es
realmente un trabajo papel de moderador
para todos
es un periodista que quiere entrevistar
la prioridad es necesario y humilde su
billete de 1.000
pero tendrá el debate un impacto en los
votantes
mucho no he hecho mi elección espero
muchas cosas espero detalles de los dos
candidatos
no cambiará mi decisión no veré más que
nada porque tengo curiosidad no para
decidirme realmente
no creo que lo vea porque no espero
mucho son dos candidatos que no me
gustan nada
para garantizar la imparcialidad los
candidatos han sorteado el lugar en el
que se sentarán en el plato y quien
hablará primero ma jin lepén estará a la
derecha y comenzará al debate también se
ha acordado la temperatura del estudio
19 grados centígrados para evitar el
sudor en directo se utilizarán 16
cámaras para filmar el encuentro en 2017
16 millones y medio de franceses
siguieron el debate la cifra de
audiencia más baja desde 1974 loca sipse
y los invito a que hoy sintonicen
france24 a las 1345 de ciudad de méxico
bogotá quito y lima ya que tenemos una
transmisión especial con el debate
presidencial en francia presentado por
maría clara calle con el análisis de
expertos invitados y la participación de
nuestras corresponsales
hasta aquí este repaso informativo sigan
conectados a france 24 y recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en france 24 punto com
[Música]